thank you very much when do we
what presentation I hope
the power of my word will do something
for your subject matter now ladies and
gentlemen first of all I'd like to thank
you for including me since I'm in many
ways an outsider to do the issue here
but maybe I could and might something
contribute to how do we deal with as
international community with the facts
of destruction post-conflict actually
hadn't won a sec by the way this book is
just out from her and a very solid and
excellent foundation for to discuss the
Bosnia case which I will now do actually
what why did the international community
react in such a way as it did in
bosnia-herzegovina where while during
the war it was basically an onlooker
there was not much activity at part from
registering the destruction but the UN
forces for example never took the task
upon them to defend or to protect the
cultural sites in Bosnia and Herzegovina
now my task is to talk about response
what has the international community
actually then and I would like to share
with you some of my own very practical
experience having been the so-called
high representative of the international
community for Bosnia and Herzegovina
around the turn of the century 1999 to
2002 actually two crucial years after
the war in in the implementation of the
Dayton Peace Accords as some of you
might recall United States led
humanitarian intervention spotted war in
Bosnia Herzegovina and it was again the
United States who introduced and who led
the peace effort which
then produced to the dayton peace accord
by the way one of the most ambitious
peace treaties around and because the
goal was and still is nothing less than
State Building now Dayton is remarkable
for several reasons for do politically
speaking clearly this was the US
unipolar moment where the United States
could indeed dictate what should happen
it was also this kind of feeling of
positive feeling I would say of this
kind of liberal imperialism I can do
mentality when stopping in particular
Wars and asymmetric conflict now the
dayton peace accord with the consent of
the government of bosnia herzegovina and
the neighboring countries croatia and
yugoslavia dens molly was lava of
Milosevic yugoslavia turned bosnia tag
arena in this sort of a semi semi
International Protectorate which was
based on two pillars the military and
civilian but what the military was
extremely important in the beginning
when it was still lots of tensions
around and nobody was really sure
whether it would not fall back into yet
another military conflict now the
civilian part of the bc fermentation
efforts which I was in charge of was the
so-called office of the High
Representative this is an ad-hoc
international organization that was
specifically designed for the
implementation of the data under codes
it is indeed part of the Dayton Accords
as one of the annexes now the so-called
high representative data the top civil
administrator is the final authority in
theater as
the Accords put out with two very
important features the High
Representative as a person this is
directly vested into his position to
impose legislation and to dismiss by
decree public figures which
unfortunately I had to do more than 100
times now the stated goal of the day can
record was to reverse the impact of
ethnic cleansing to preserve the unity
of the state and to bring back in
particular the more than 2 million
refugees and idps internally displaced
persons of course the priorities at the
beginning were far more directed towards
the humanitarian issues that this was
really a fight about the sheer survivor
and also to create a safe and secure
environment both for the population as
well as for the international community
which went there at the beginning as
around 60,000 military and several
hundred ten several thousand civilians
working there both diplomats
government's international the national
officials as well as NGOs now as I've
already mentioned the centerpiece of the
dead in the code really is to bring back
the expelled population as i said the
population of all together a barely four
million and more than fifty percent were
expelled and the issue of course was how
how do we actually counter the ethnic
cleansing the terrible word for
something and what what actually spells
success and success in bringing back
refugees and idps was really do can they
go back into territories into areas
where they then where they are part of
the minority of either serbs croats or
Bosniaks now in
thousand and this is quite interesting I
was yet as I said between 99 and 2000 to
there was a breakthrough in in minority
or returns even Human Rights Watch which
is usually not very friendly with
international organizations speaking of
the breakthrough and very positive terms
about the work that we are doing there
it was a coincidence that also in the
year 2000 actually UNESCO led efforts to
to bring to deal with the cultural
devastation there came to an end it was
handed over to the local government now
one thing is important to mention and
this is that actually this is the first
piece tricky and there are not many
others I used to negotiate han bui
agreement for for bosnia for kosovo and
there the the cultural aspect is
mentioned but not that as prominently as
in the case of bosnia-herzegovina where
the annex 8 actually created a
commission to preserve national
monuments and x8 was in the first couple
of years of a rather limited success and
unesco guidance there was a list of
monuments that was created but there was
no formal process to speak of how to go
about but then the year 2000 when when
more and more refugees found a way back
into the original villages and small
towns usually that they started the sort
of where i would say interplay between
the two dayton provisions this is an x 7
refugee return in one hand and nx8 as
the commission to preserve national
monuments on the other hand and clearly
it was
and that was pointed out in Helens
presentation already it was mostly
Muslim sacred buildings mosque that were
destroyed in this in a very systematic
way because the idea on the syrup side
was really to create what they what he
referred to as a greater serbia project
now we had the we on the other hand
international community we had to
consider in order to make the returns
sustainable that rehabilitation the
reconstruction was very important this
is the other side it was used to reverse
the ethnic cleansing so to speak the
physical cleansing if you if you may in
order to make it as sustainable which of
course includes to sort of recreate a
set a sense of belonging also safety
security is very much attached to this
in short to stabilize those those
communities there who were shaken so
authority and of course it was is oil it
was also thought to be some sort of
adventure reconciliation and
truth-finding exercise which will have
to come under way eventually there we
also need to clearly deal with a
systematic destruction of cultural
monuments now the question of course is
also that the interesting thing that
happened is that with the increasing
returns and more and more efforts which
were frustrated in the first couple of
years to rebuild this mosque this led to
several violent clashes and incidents
particularly dominated areas like two
occasions in bond a look at the capital
of
the serb dominated and aunt Edie
republika srpska we're a corner stone
laying ceremony was ambushed by
extremists and hooligans and also
another one in now that serve dominated
ton of traveling not far away from from
Dubrovnik if you know where Dubrovnik is
a cravat and one hour's drive but inside
of Bosnia and Herzegovina not in Croatia
where the government is now this made it
necessary to thoroughly reconsider
actually how to move forward in the
implementation of this nh-8 and the
commission a burden my office decided on
taking a wholly new approach which which
was basically based or say two on two
elements through a two-track approach if
you may first and foremost to harmonize
legislation in the country at the
different layers of governance that
existed there created by the data
network far too / convoluted and far too
complex but it's just a fact and this
legislation basically served to to
hinder and to obstruct any meaningful
action they are not just in the cultural
field of course in many other fields as
well and secondly to to reconstitute
this commission for the cultural
monuments at the time and when I when in
preparing for this for this small in
short lecture I went over over the
papers from that time and there I reread
a letter with which I wrote to the
UNESCO Director General at the time
where I complained about the Byzantine
jungle of non-uniform laws concerning
construction permit application it's
kind of a hyperbolic the language but it
also expresses
the frustration that we were confronted
with now what horrid was a drawn-out
negotiation process working groups were
set in drafting drafting sessions took
place and I had basically to mediate
between local actors international
community the security aspect for
example the stabilization force there
were nato-led was not very happy about
those violent incidents because they
were in charge of safe and secure
environment now thanks to the powers
invested in me and this needs to be
underlined here as high representative
eventually amended the laws and I
imposed in a republic of srpska the
whole legislation because the National
Assembly dia simply would not have done
its job now at the same time and let me
just mention those few examples which
took place in Mille taneously and that
was what my decision on the location of
the cemetery for describing its victims
as well as the missing persons
initiative dna-based the identification
process that took place and we also very
much supported the ICP why do you miss
Olivia tribunal to include cultural
genocide in it said on the other hand
there were also business activities
where one who was trying to so to speak
disrupt this cultural reconstructions of
course this all was intended to foster
normalization and to support the
community building efforts now 15 years
on bosnia-herzegovina is still very much
divided society I'm afraid it's on a
downward spiral and but there are also
some positive things first of all the
the Commission the annex 8 Commission is
arguable dear only success story when it
comes to the state level institutions in
bosnia-herzegovina we know that all the
so-called national museums and galleries
are closed
money for this but above all there is no
common narrative for a state of
bosnia-herzegovina maybe we will speak
later on about the lessons because they
are some that could be drawn from
bosnia-herzegovina thank you so much